bonjour à tous alors de quoi on parle
depuis tout à l'heure on parle de
résilience on parle de paradigme on
parle de d'excellence de performance
tout un tout un vocabulaire qui est
propre aussi au domaine de l'entreprise
moi je vais vous raconter une histoire
d'amour qui me tient à coeur depuis
depuis pas mal de temps
j'ai mis un j'ai mis un long chemin pour
y arriver
mais au bout d'un jeu direct finalement
le m a été aussi un élément déclencheur
suite à une formation j'ai suivi en
formation professionnelle il ya une
dizaine d'années je me suis dit que la
passion que j'avais pour l'art la
passion que j'avais pour l'entreprise et
la passion de communiqué je pouvais en
faire quelque chose je suis parti d'une
feuille blanche et je me suis dit aussi
également que l'entreprise dans le monde
dans lequel on vit et c'est conforter
aujourd'hui par par cette actualité qui
personnellement me perturbe aussi
beaucoup c'est que l'entreprise doit
aussi essayer d'apprendre à exprimer sa
sensibilité
on est dans une école qui prône le
business qui prône la performance qui
prône la rentabilité le résultat net
mais si demain je vais voir un
entrepreneur un grand patron jeu
l'interview et je lui dis mais est-ce
que vous avez une sensibilité ce que
vous pouvez l'exprimer là il va me
regarder d'un oeil bizarre ce qui va
dire mais de quoi elle parle qu'est ce
qu'elle veut qu'est ce qu'elle veut me
dire
mais si on arrive ensemble à s'entendre
il va se passer des belles choses ce qui
a fait que ce projet est né aussi ccd
éléments enfin en tout cas les croyances
je suis convaincu que lorsqu'on veut
fortement passionnément et constamment
on obtient toujours et on arrive à notre
atteindre notre objectif
donc je disais qu'au préalable jamais
l'art large les j'ai été formé après mon
bac dans une école d'art on m'a dit pour
des raisons personnelles 20 céline non
l'art sata viendra nulle part donc il
faut que tu trouves une autre voie donc
j'ai cherché pareil
où est ce que je pouvais amener mon mes
compétences je ne voulais pas qu'il
fasse de l'argent frais de la com facile
il ya 25 ans en arrière là comme avait
un grand territoire de jeu
et puis je crois que quand on a une
passion en soit elle est toujours
présente donc l'art a toujours été dans
ma vie personnelle avec des expositions
des rencontres etc et fort d'un parcours
professionnel ou une fois j'avais
atteint la quête du graal on va dire
après une formation à le m après des
postes qui vous emmène au niveau
international on voyage on prend les
avions et puis on se dit finalement
qu'est-ce que les gens retiennent de ce
que je suis en train de faire peut-être
pas grand-chose
et puis finalement on est on est amené à
se construire soi même
donc il ya dix ans j'ai tout remis à
plat j'y vais partir d'une feuille
blanche et j'ai exprimé aux entreprises
que à travers l'art elle va pouvoir
changer le rapport
si j'étais libre de mes faits et gestes
déjà je changerais la donne c'est bien
je serai pas sur la scène mais je serai
à côté de vous et je vais vous
l'exprimez d'une manière différente
parce que je suis plutôt un agitateur de
de relations de
de dialogue de conviction j'aime voir
les gens différemment et j'aime que les
gens regardent différemment
donc comment l'art peut exprimer une
sensibilité et comment grâce à l'artiste
grâce à des designers grâce à la lecture
ou de la danse lente regarder
différemment alors je suis un peu
destructive comme me le disait certains
consultants qu'on travaille avec moi sur
cette cette intervention et je vais vous
donner un exemple j'ai un notaire qui
est venu me voir ou même que je suis
allé voir on va être un peu humble c'est
pas qu'il fallait le chercher en me
disant je trouve des clients parce que
c'est bien beau de dire que l'entreprise
peut exprimer une sensibilité mais qui
va me faire confiance et qui va suivre
sur ma route ce chemin là je suis allé
voir des notaires donc j'espère qu'il ya
pas de notaire dans la salle mais donc
profession très installé on pourrait
peut-être dire pour certains très
classique sans avoir des préjugés mais
c'est une profession en tout cas qu'il
n'a pas le droit de communiquer en tout
cas il ya sept huit ans elle en arrière
et qui a des règles déontologiques et
qui ne peut pas faire de la publicité en
tant que tel je suis allé voir le
notaire qui avaient des associés et je
lui dit écoutez voilà dominique on va on
va essayer de travailler ensemble sur la
présentation d'une artiste chez vous et
on va exposer une artiste qui est en
même temps en résonance au musée de
saint-etienne qui s'appelle françoise
pétrovitch je suis avec mes poupées l'a
donc là c'est devenu compliqué parce que
il me regardait avec des poupées des
membres et chez des notaires je suis pas
sûr que le résultat va être probants et
en fait ce notaire dominique est un
homme qui sait sortir du cadre et qui a
aussi eu l'audace peut-être de me faire
confiance et de se dire cet artiste elle
a un parcours
elle est suivie dans les institutions
elle veut dire des choses et le travail
sur ce qu'on voit ce qu'on ne voit pas
l'adolescence la pureté de l'adolescence
mais aussi la dureté des enfants comment
je vais pouvoir exprimer mais ça à
travers mes clients et et mes
partenaires
donc les collaborateurs sont arrivés sur
tous les associés ils ont crié au loup
mon dieu comment pouvez-vous présenter
autant de
de difficultés en fin de dessin assez
raide à montrer donc là on a travaillé
sur la relation et petit à petit on a
changé la donne c'est à dire
qu'effectivement on était plus face à
face comme là je le suis aujourd'hui
avec vous mais je me suis mis à côté
d'eux donc je vous tourne le dos mais
bon c'est pas c'est pas le plus probant
pour vous expliquer on s'est mis à côté
avec l'artiste dont françoise pétrovitch
est venu à lyon
et elle a essayé de dialoguer en tout
cas avec des jalles interne pour leur
expliquer son propos moi je ne suis pas
là pour faire de la décoration
ce qui est important c'est qu'on change
le dialogue et qu'on regarde
différemment donc une oeuvre d'art
effectivement dans une entreprise ce qui
donne son sang c'est quand on va pouvoir
décrypter donc ça a donné lieu
effectivement à des échanges à des
rencontres avec le personnel mais aussi
avec des clients avec des institutions
et chacun a pu discuter avec elles et
exprimés soit son rejet soit son émotion
soit son incompréhension mais ce qu'ont
retenu en tout cas le public est venu à
cette exposition
c'était un vrai dialogue de concertation
et de et de relation différente à l'art
pour pouvoir essayer de comprendre son
propos ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on met
en danger les les acteurs quand on parle
de d'entreprise ou d'artistes je dirais
on à l'artiste avec nous aujourd'hui
j'aime bien les sortir de leur zone de
confort l'artiste qui vient dans une
entreprise et puis en fait on le on lui
dit mme attention vous êtes
habituellement dans une belle boîte
blanche donc la boîte blanche et la
galerie normalement les gens ne viennent
que pour lui que pour découvrir son art
souvent en ciel
et moi je dis attention on va plus venir
que pour vous parce qu'on va venir dans
l'entreprise donc on va travailler un
accrochage différemment on va être
obligé de tenir compte du contexte et de
l'environnement l'entreprise va être
sollicitée et va être peut-être critiqué
pour le choix arbitraire keller a fait
et en même temps le client qui va venir
finalement il va venir pourquoi il va
venir parce qu'il est motivé parce qu'il
ya une entreprise qu'il invite donc
c'est le patron fin le dirigeant les
associés peu importe il va dire j'ai à
manger quand même ça faut pas l'oublier
on est à lyon capitale de la gastronomie
dont qui est un bon cocktail est un bon
chef ça va ça va me motiver pour se
déplacer peut-être parce qu'il se dit je
connais l'artiste donc ça va me donner
du sens et je vais la redécouvrir dans
une autre dans une autre expérience et
puis parce que je vais aussi profiter de
mon réseau pour montrer que je suis un
peu cultivé ça il faut pas être dans
l'utopie quand on introduit l'art dans
l'entreprise les gens aussi peuvent s'en
servir pour être un vecteur de 2
d'être mieux cultiver d'être plus
cultivé et de se dire j'étais là au bon
moment au bon endroit
en tout cas quand tous ces éléments sont
réunis après il faut être un chef
d'orchestre et il faut pouvoir manipuler
tout ça avec intelligence bienveillance
pour que l'artiste se sentent à l'aise
parce qu'effectivement il est d'ors hors
de son contexte que l'entreprise allant
sortent grandis et surtout que le public
soit averti d'un d'une nouvelle
connaissance et d'une nouvelle
sensibilité pour pouvoir garder en
mémoire ce qui l'a rencontré et de se
dire plus tard quand il verra l'artiste
dans un musée ou dans une autre galerie
dans un autre chemin dia ah mais oui
c'est grâce à dominique que j'ai pu
découvrir tel artiste ou c'est grâce à
un tel que j'ai mémorisé ce qu'elle
faisait et j'ai travaillé sur l'intimité
aussi de cette relation
puisqu'on a un vrai dialogue est un vrai
échange avec l'artiste
je dirais que l'élément qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui je pense qu'une
entreprise elle doit exprimer cette
sensibilité à travers les arts multiples
c'est qu'effectivement une entreprise
qui n'est ni et innovante ni créative
elle se meurt
aujourd'hui on est dans la remise en
question je crois que la parenthèse que
j'apporte quand on travaille au sein de
cette entreprise avec des artistes
on travaille sur l'expression d'un art
on est dans une autre relation et on est
surtout côte à côte
ensemble ça je me répète mais c'est
vraiment tellement important pour se
dire que on va essayer d'avoir une même
lecture avec des éléments de langage
différent mais essayer d'apprécier tous
ensemble quelqu'un ou pas moi je dis
bien je ne suis pas là pour faire un
compromis et l'idée c'est que
l'entreprise puisse exprimer ce qu'elle
ressent à travers cet artiste et puis
pour finir je dirais que hegel a dit une
chose qui moi m'a toujours animé par
rapport à ma vocation à travers l'art
c'est que rien dans ce monde ne se fait
sans passion et qu'à travers la passion
quoi que vous fassiez si vous exprimez
votre excellence et votre
professionnalisme
vous irez toujours vert vers un projet
professionnel abouti
voilà je vous remercie